welcome back to CBS morning because it's
been nearly three weeks since a fiery
trained derailment in East Palestine
Ohio exposed an entire Community to
potentially hazardous chemicals now the
EPA says it's taking over the cleanup
process and ordering rail operator
Norfolk Southern to pay for it now there
are calls for change to make sure
nothing like this ever happens again but
the question now is how did this happen
in the first place Roxanna severe has
been looking into that and she's in
Youngstown Ohio Roxanna good to see you
people there have a lot of questions
still
they do good morning Gail the NTSB
report detailing the causes of this
incident is not expected for another
year or so but there are several factors
in the ways trains operate across the
country that could have contributed to
This Disaster a disaster that has left
many people in this community frustrated
and scared
it was a waste of two hours a waste well
sure Matthew Stokes who works near the
site of the toxic train derailment says
the State's new medical clinic didn't
help him with his headache or chest pain
I did talk to the toxicologists there's
nothing they can do
while people here wait to learn about
possible health risks officials are
stepping up pressure on Norfolk Southern
in the face of Norfolk Southern's
arrogance and incompetence I want you to
know we are fighting back EPA
administrator Michael Regan announced he
was ordering the rail operator to pay
for the whole cleanup of East Palestine
or suffer the consequences if the
company fails to complete any action
ordered by EPA
the agency will immediately step in
conduct the work ourselves and then
Force Norfolk Southern to pay triple in
cost but the kind of train that derailed
in East Palestine highlights a growing
cost-cutting strategy in the rail
industry known as Precision scheduled
railroading which seeks to streamline
rail operations by lengthening trains
while cutting the workforce the train
that derailed on February 3rd stretched
9 300 feet long weighed a whopping 18
000 tons and had around 150 cars how
would you address this trend
look this has been part of a drive by
these multi-billion dollar companies to
ring every penny of profit out of the
rail system they have cut their
Workforce massively including safety
positions including maintenance
positions between 2011 and 2021 the
number of workers at the largest U.S
rail companies decreased by 28 percent
over the same period of time net revenue
increased by around 58 percent what I
can tell you from our members on the
ground is they feel like safety has
degraded Greg Regan is the president of
the afl-cio's transportation trades
Department there is a real empty to go
faster and so we've seen that pressure
decrease the inspection times from about
two minutes down to an average of 30 to
45 seconds he says data from the Federal
Railroad Administration shows the rate
of accidents has increased over the last
10 years particularly in Rail Yards
yesterday the Department of
Transportation called on the entire
industry to immediately make several
changes is like using technology to
improve inspections and replacing older
tank cars with newer more secure ones
something rail companies have long
resisted and Congress has not made a
priority we definitely need
congressional action we need some of the
people who have stood with industry to
stand on the side of safety instead do
you think East Palestine is a wake-up
call
I think that none of us can look at what
happened there and say that everything
should continue just the way it was
before
in a statement Norfolk Southern said we
are going to learn from this terrible
accident and work with regulators and
elected officials to improve railroad
safety today former president Trump will
visit the area he won 70 percent of the
vote in the county in 2020. Nate
Roxanna thank you
you know Norfolk Southern uh their CEO
said look we put a billion dollars a
year into safety we reinvested in our
railroad I think the question though
from people watching this is yeah but
you're making billions more than that
you had some excess you could have done
war and also the length of that train I
mean we're talking well over a mile
almost two miles in length and did they
take the time to do little safety things
like move the heavier cars up front so
if there is a fire you can stop the
train more quickly maybe it never makes
it to the town these are the kind of
questions that people are asking and I
think the people there still don't know
are they in danger what are the
long-time ramifications for this you
hear about the headaches and the coughs
and people not feeling well and nobody
seems to know exactly what the real
effects are at this particular time it's
scary the good news if the federal
government holds a Norfolk Southern
accountable and they have to pay they
clearly have the money revenue's been
going through the roof I'm no
mathematician but a decrease in workers
increase in Revenue equals these types
of accidents it's not a good equation it
can happen that way